[Música]
você já se olhou no espelho e desejou
que qualquer outra pessoa eu passei toda
a minha pré adolescência ea minha
infância odiando o meu cabelo
todas as mulheres da minha família tem
cabelo liso e eu estudei como dez anos
com o bolsista numa escola particular
onde todas as minhas colegas de turma
também tinha um cabelo liso
isso fazia com que cada vez mais eu me
senti diferente delas eu não me sentia
bonita
eu me lembro que quando estava no
período da tarde na escola
toda vez na hora do almoço eu lavava o
meu cabelo e plantéis durante o dia eu
ia no banheiro e ficava jogando água
nele para que ele ficasse abaixada ficar
se comportado
o problema surgiu quando eu comecei a
cidade de manhã eu não tinha tempo mas
lavar todo o cabelo todos os dias
então eu comecei a andar com ele só peso
eu pegava o meu cabelo com toda força é
prendia ele e puxava como psicólogos
colonizadora a minha raiz fazia rabo de
cavalo e coque logo em seguida passar
uma grande quantidade de joão porque
assim ficava arrumado novamente
eu me lembro que uma vez aos 13 anos de
idade
eu decidi cometer uma loucura eu fui ao
salão de beleza sozinha eu ia somente
cortar as pontas do meu cabelo
nessa época eu tinha o cabelo na altura
do quadril
então eu peguei e pedir para que a
brasileira cortar seu cabelo como uma
inspiração de uma trilha de novela da
globo que estava passando
ela tinha o cabelo bem curtinho aquele
estilo chanel todo liso achava ela é
maravilhosa eu queria ser igual a ela
então eu pedi para que ela abortasse
igual ela cortou lá vou eu já tô secou e
quando ela me virou de frente para o
espelho pela primeira vez na vida me
sentir bonita pela primeira vez na vida
eu queria saiu no dia seguinte de manhã
quando eu fui para a escola eu decidi
lavar o meu cabelo
foi aí que tudo começou o meu cabelo
simples
devido ao corte não ser favorável meu
tipo de cabelo não fica uma coisa
harmoniosa para o meu rosto mas mesmo
assim começava atrasado não tinha tempo
de escovar ele a decidir assim mesmo
eu me lembro até hoje quando eu pisei no
pé na sala estava todo mundo conversando
em um grupo de meninos que sentava ao
lado contrário onde eu me sentava na
sala começou a rir muito alto até que um
deles apontou pra mim disse
eu vou avisar minha avó que a vassoura
que ela usa pra varrer o quintal fugiu
de casa
nessa hora a sala inteira começou a rir
ea minha única vontade era sair dali
correndo embora pra casa
eu passei o resto da aula como chorando
por dentro e contando os minutos para
poder sair dali
eu me lembro que quando o professor
liberou deu sinal eu fui a primeira a
sair da sala e corre para o banheiro
eu sentei em uma das cabines no chão e
comecei a chorar
eu chorava muito eu tenho vontade de
pegar o meu cabelo e arrancar lhe com as
minhas mãos
eu queria sumir nunca mais voltar à
escola isso continuou dias após dias as
piadinhas nunca paravam todo dia ele se
alimentava uma nova até que certo dia eu
cansei
eu simplesmente cansei porque eles estão
falando a mesma coisa eles tentavam me
ofender e falar algo do meu cabelo e
aquilo já estava de saco cheio pra mim
então eu conheço ignorá los
e quando eu comecei a ignorá los eu
comecei a perceber que eu podia ser
outra pessoa eu podia começar a gostar
mais do meu cabelo e não vi aquelas
críticas que falavam que meu cabelo
estava muita má armado que meu cabelo
era definido que o de viabilizar aquele
cabelo eu parei de ouvir todas as
opiniões e procurei buscar o contrário
foi quando com a ajuda da minha mãe que
foi uma das pessoas mais importantes na
minha vida
a gente chegou e começou a pesquisar
várias dicas coisas como exemplo como
lavar o cabelo como enxágua com o
pentear como finalizar quais produtos
utilizar uma coisa que há cinco anos
atrás era algo raro
você é o supermercado você não
encontrava nas prateleiras produtos para
cabelo cacheado você encontrava
paralisados ou é uma coisa importada uma
coisa muito cara não é uma coisa
acessível
ainda mais pra minha família e era uma
coisa e quando você pesquisar na
internet em uma outra pessoa falava mas
não direcional exatamente no cabelo
cacheado outubro foi uma coisa muito
difícil de aprender durante muito muito
a pesquisa a gente acumula informações e
eu peguei uma forma de brincar fazer e
falei pra minha mãe eu quero criar uma
fantasia no facebook para poder passar
as informações para outras meninas e
assim ajudá las a se aceitarem como
estou me aceitando porque não foi uma
ocorrência da noite pro dia quando os
meninos começaram a isolar e do nada
passei a ignorar o outro e nosso vou
começar a me ama mais
não foi assim demorou anos e anos
então eu criei a rede social todos os
dias eu ia lá e postar alguma coisa que
eu mesmo havia pesquisado com minhas
próprias palavras
escrevi um post publicado fiz isso por
durante um mês
de repente eu parei de me das obrigações
de escola e estava porque estava
entrando no ensino médio então decidi
focar somente nos estudos
quase um ano depois eu decidi voltar
para essa rede social de 600 pessoas que
me acompanhavam naquela época eu fazia
os posts passou para 300 mil pessoas e
essas pessoas cada vez mais pediu para
que eu postar se daqui eu ensinar se
elas da síndica pra elas
e cada vez mais as mensagens apareceram
relatos de mulheres falando que eu
estava influenciando elas aceitarem se
gostarem passarem pelo processo de
transição capilar que os processos mais
difíceis na última cacheada é quando a
mulher decide largar de alisar o cabelo
e voltar para os cachos
é quando ela passa uma mistura de
sentimentos de uma mistura de emoções e
de opiniões
foram coisas que eu ouvir quando decide
cortar o meu cabelo que eu sei o quanto
é difícil e aqui eu fui me inspirando
cada vez mais acontecer
com essa rede social cada vez ele
apostando mais eu interagiram com os
leitores e de 300 mil seguidores em
menos de um ano passou para 1 milhão
eu não imaginava que um milhão de
pessoas acompanharam a menina de 16 anos
de idade
aquilo pra mim era fora do normal e
novamente menos de um ano em torno de
sete oito meses eu consegui mais um
milhão de seguidores mas sim totalizando
2 milhões de pessoas começaram a me
acompanhar
foi quando elas pediram para que eu
mostrasse quem eu era de verdade porque
apesar de tudo este momento de aceitação
nesse processo de querer ver quem
realmente era cuidar do meu cabelo eu
odiava tirar foto
eu raramente tirava uma foto até com a
minha família porque eu me sentia
horrível ainda eu ajudava as outras
pessoas mas ao mesmo tempo estava
imprimindo tava estava entre prevê vindo
foi quando elas pediram para que eu
começasse a fazer vídeos explicando
aquele conteúdo que eu passava pelas em
forma de push
nessa hora eu congelei porque eu não me
mostrava ninguém sabia quem era quem era
menina cards mas por um ato de coragem
como eu tive o ato de cortar o cabelo e
começar tudo isso eu comecei a gravar
esses vídeos e as pessoas começaram a me
reconhecer e cada vez mais cada vez que
eu recebo mensagem emotiva continuar
logo em seguida criou outras redes
sociais como o instagram eu compartilho
meu dia a dia de um adolescente normal
que aos 18 anos de idade faz rota baile
atualmente com essas redes sociais e
cada vez mais pessoas me seguem pessoas
me mandam mensagem dizendo que eu sou
inspiração delas
e toda essa reviravolta que teve na
minha vida de uma menina que não
aceitava o cabelo e dia tudo custo para
que a mãe pudesse realizar o ponto de
chorar a implorar para ela é uma menina
que fez isso uma forma de trabalho
eu levo dois ensinamentos muito básicos
para a minha vida e é uma coisa que eu
sei que vocês já devem ter ouvido ruídos
a primeira é a primeira é se ame
não importa o que aconteça o primeiro
passo é você
cobriu seu eu verdadeiro não julgue não
queira diminuir as suas características
características
existem mais de 7 bilhões de pessoas no
mundo
cada uma delas se diferencia das outras
por coisas físicas mentais e físicas ou
mentais porque você quer ser outra
pessoa se você pode ser você mesmo
essa é uma das que essa é uma das frases
que mais passou pelas minhas leitoras
é uma das coisas que elas mas tem que
colocar no dia a dia
a segunda lição é gratidão eu sei que há
gente no dia a dia na correria a gente
acaba de esquecendo de agradecer pelas
coisas simples mas é uma coisa que tem
que fazer não importa o que você tem a
agradecer seja o seu cabelo seja sua cor
seja o seu nariz seja o seu emprego a
sua vida sua família agradeço por tudo
isso porque tem pessoas que rezam para
ter a vida que você tem e você nem
imagina agora deixa um questionamento
pra vocês
você já se olhar no espelho hoje e o
reflexo que vocês viram
você já mataram ele obrigada
[Aplausos]